[Music]
hello
and welcome to the week in 60 minutes
brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on july the 22nd
my name is freddie gray i am the
spectator's world
edition editor and i'm going to be your
host today
on today's show we are going to be
talking about
freedom or the lack of it and the
possibility that vaccine passports are
back on the agenda i'll be joined by
kate andrews and mark woolpot to talk
about it
after that we're going to talk to
douglas murray about
freedom itself and whether the british
people actually want to be free
at all then we'll do a little section on
politics we'll talk to katie and james
about what's happening in westminster
and then after that we're going to do a
section on
afghanistan and whether the west is
right to withdraw i'll be talking to
andrew coburn
and tom tuggenheart and then finally
we're going to be talking to sam leath
our literary editor who had the great
misfortune
of having his car stolen you should
probably subscribe to the spectator
magazine
too if you missed out on our pims offer
last week
we've got another great deal for you get
12 weeks of the magazine
for just 12 pounds and we'll give you on
top of that a
free 20 pound amazon voucher completely
free
that's three months of the spectator
delivered to your door
and available online for just 12 pounds
and a free 20 pound amazon voucher just
go to www.spectator.co.uk.forwardslash
tv
offer to take it up now first up
freedom day monday was allegedly freedom
day but it's
been and gone and we don't feel
necessarily more free
and i'm going to talk to kate andrews
who's our economics editor
and we're going to be discussing her
cover piece in which she talks about how
vaccine passports covet certificate
identification
is back on the agenda she'll be joined
by sir mark
walpot who was the government scientific
advisor between
2013-2017 now
kate in your companies this week you
talk about the fact that not so
long ago uh maybe a few weeks
the british government seemed to be on a
roll
the vaccine rollout was going very well
the government
seemed to have a clear strategy as to
what it was doing
in terms of fighting covid and in the
last three weeks
that's all gone a bit wrong and
everything's become a little bit
unhinged what has actually happened well
ministers don't want to talk about it
but they were
pursuing a strategy of herd immunity for
the autumn
not the way it was previously talked
about when you would just have mass
infection with no vaccines to protect
the vulnerable
but one in which people were building up
antibodies either through natural
infection but predominantly now
through vaccination a very different
kind of strategy from the one before but
still
one way we reached herd immunity come
september october time
and the delta variant changed that
equation it's far more contagious
and they think that the threshold to
achieve herd immunity is much higher
and so the fact that there seems to be
more vaccine hesitancy among the young
has meant that they've ramped up
rhetoric that does not sound so much
like freedom day
but actually a very new and quite
sinister normal
where we're not going back to our old
ways but we're ushering in
a new era where we will have a tiered
society
where people who are double-jabbed will
have significantly more rights to travel
to access certain kinds of venues than
people
who aren't jabbed and and i think
there are a lot of issues with this one
the fact that we have not even had a
proper debate in
parliament yet the second that ministers
promised in the winter time
michael gove nadeem swahili former
health secretary matt hancock that they
weren't even considering something like
this
nadim sawahi called it discriminatory
which it would be
by nature and yet now we're in a
situation where the government is
announcing it
as a fact as i say in the cover piece
some people are calling their bluff
they're saying the government does not
actually intend to bring in vaccine
passports this is a
cynical ploy to get more young people to
take up the vaccine
but i think uh you know it's it it
doesn't
it almost doesn't matter whether it's
cynical or not although it certainly
will matter if it's
not and they're planning to bring them
in and our lives change in that way
it's a fundamental break uh in in the
trust that we were supposed to have in
our government that
they were leading us through this and
being honest every step in the way
every step of the way now we're at a
point where they're saying to us
i'm sorry but it's it's not going to be
as it once was we're moving into
something that looks a lot more like a
biosecurity state and um it's not
obvious that this is what
what people have signed up for i want to
get back to vaccine possible in seconds
but but
first of all the delta variant uh has
happened
we can't really blame the government for
for the delta variant but perhaps we can
blame the government don't you think
for uh suggesting hope that it was
perhaps
beyond its reach well i mean it is a
communications balance between being
you know hopelessly optimistic or indeed
severely pessimistic and that is a very
challenging line to follow
but i really disagree with the idea that
there's something sinister going on here
um and this has sort of become almost a
libertarian battleground
um but i i think one's got to look at it
rather carefully because
it of course it's people's liberty in a
sense not to have a vaccine and to
receive the harms that flow if you get
infected
but the issue here is that vaccination
protects you
from infecting other people and so
that's a quite different argument and in
many countries including the united
states
you basically can't go to school until
you've had a whole set of vaccines
you can't go to harvard if you don't
have an annual flu injection
in france and in italy compulsory
vaccinations
in childhood are the the norman have
been for a long time
there are all sorts of situations where
we legislate behavior
um and you know to some extent it is not
only to protect yourself but others
seat belts uh there are all sorts of
examples
and so it doesn't seem to me to be the
most sort of terrible thing
that actually if you want to go into an
environment
and it is basically indoors
crowded poorly ventilated spaces where
transmission is most likely to come
happen then actually saying well if you
want to do that
then you need to have two vaccines uh
this is not really a fundamental assault
on liberty
i suppose i i see what you're saying but
i suppose the objection and i don't
think it's just mad libertarians
uh that think this is that uh there
seemed to be a public debate
and the government seemed to have in
fact said it was not going to go ahead
with the
with vaccine passports uh particularly
not domestic vaccine passports
and yet now it's happening so people
feel that there's a sort of frivolous
public debate
that actually doesn't happen and there's
no parliamentary scrutiny as kate says
and then these things yeah it's clearly
a good thing to have a public debate and
we're having the debate here
what's the point in the problem but of
course you know as the facts change
people have to change their plans and
you know this is in a sense
a uh when i don't really like using sort
of
war-like metaphors but um the virus
obeys one set of laws which is the laws
of darwinian evolution
um and essentially those variants of the
virus that make it able to transmit more
easily
and those behaviors by humans that make
it easier to transmit
more easily are good for the virus and
bad for us
and the challenge is it's not as though
this is a completely benign disease if
you're young
it's predominantly young people that are
ending up in hospital
and if they've had a pneumonia even if
it doesn't kill them there's a
significant risk that they'll have quite
long-term lung disease
and so the sort of specter of long covid
which is a whole variety of different
things
is quite significant and it's a much
nastier infection than flu and you don't
really want to have flu either so
it seems to me that you know the
government did not anticipate that they
would have 50 000 cases a day merely
of a new variant at the time when they
were hoping to
open up the vaccination program has been
an extraordinary success
but perhaps not surprisingly as it
reaches younger age groups who feel
themselves more sort of immortal
there is a bit more hesitancy and this
does two things i mean a
it does actually if if if introduced in
this form it does incentivize them to do
it
can we say that at the end today that's
got to be a good thing to do can we say
the vaccination program has been such a
success certainly the initial rollout
was successful uh but it seems to be
slowing down
and it seems that the vaccine is not as
successful in stopping transmission
as was first anticipated no it was never
i mean frankly the vaccines have been
much more successful than the scientific
community expected in the first place to
get so i mean
i mean firstly almost 90 of adults have
now had
one vaccine dose and they're heading
towards the second days that's pretty
successful program i mean
much more than in almost every other
country in the world
and secondly it's always recognized that
there's a sort of threshold of
effectiveness of vaccines
and what the vaccines are doing is they
are largely protecting they're not
completely
people against the most severe effects
of disease so they are reducing
hospitalizations and they are reducing
death there's no doubt about that
but they are a bit less effective at
introducing mild symptomatic disease
and asymptomatic disease um and you know
frankly this is
you know humans against natural biology
um it's very difficult to overcome the
forces of nature and vaccines have been
arguably uh alongside clean water
the major public health measures that
have changed human health and survival
over the last
couple of centuries it seems as though
the government has learned from the
example of france
uh in this particular instance because
uh the french saw
an uptake in vaccination rates among
young people
when they introduced a little as you
would call it nudge as others might say
coercion
uh into into society uh kate do you
think
you know you say that uh vaccine
hesitancy will increase with coercion
but the example of france suggests that
it won't and that what not calls an
inertia
uh might go down with a bit more nudging
well i think if you're genuinely vaccine
hesitant i think
you know seeing the way that this
narrative has changed is is probably
going to shove you towards the skeptic
direction and but as we as we write in
this week's magazine you know the heavy
fist of the state um can actually be
very convincing and
in france we're seeing mass protest but
we've also seen uptake of the jab
amongst young people i think go up at
roughly 75 since he brought in such
extreme vaccine passport rules um it can
work the question is whether or not as a
society we are comfortable
with um this kind of not nudge but force
the threat that you will deprive a
person of their liberty
because they're not doing something that
you're claiming is voluntary
you know we also have to remember that
the government is still very insistent
that these vaccines are voluntary but
they're just going to continue to take
away parts of your life
until you do what they want and it's
moving i mean it's
just very quickly it's moving it's
moving very fast i mean about a week ago
maybe two weeks ago the
government publishes guidance for
business saying that they would help
them
to develop a system to check people's
vaccination status it was voluntary
with a little note at the bottom saying
if you don't do this by the way we do
reserve the right to make you
less than two weeks later they're making
them and you know this is what's so
incredible is that they're working with
the narrative of choice
and yet they're bringing in this force
and because parliament hasn't been
sitting properly
we haven't had the chance to call this
out properly and say wait a second
we have not actually signed up or agreed
to this it goes against our principles
is it really worth doing this but i mean
the paradox in a way
is that actually the uk is probably the
only country in the world that's sort of
taken off the breaks
in terms of social interaction at a time
when the case numbers are rising
and you know the fear is that when
you've got 50 000 a day and we haven't
really talked about all the pings but i
mean the pings actually reflect the fact
that lots of people are being exposed to
people who've tested positive i mean the
app is actually doing what it's supposed
to do
um although inevitably there are some
false positives and indeed false
negatives amongst that
so that's the paradox which is that
actually this is a government that
doesn't actually like
uh legislative controls on behavior so
the breaks have come off
but it's at a time when the uh car as it
were is traveling at
90 miles an hour down a hill that's
that's the challenge and so
you know are they going to be forced to
introduce more rules depending on what
happens with the numbers
and what the modeling does show is that
if you don't if you are cautious and the
guidance is to be cautious
then we're likely to have a smaller peak
than if you simply return to
complete pre-covert behavior so you know
it's a dilemma for the government in a
way which is
they've got a fast accelerating car are
they going to
put some form of rules back on the
environments where the transmission is
likely to be most rampant but lastly
then mark i mean
do you think the problem then is not
obviously that there is some uh
orwellian uh state in the making but
just that the government doesn't have a
clue what it's doing and in a way that's
more sinister
well i mean i just uh i pity the policy
maker it's very very difficult job
they've got at the moment i mean this is
the one of the toughest sets of
decisions
and i mean it's going to be scrutinized
in the finest detail for years to come
but it is genuinely difficult when
you've got a virus that as i say is not
really interested in policy at all
and it's a very very successful virus
this one actually and it will continue
to mutate
so they're having to make decisions on
the hoof and
you know i would rather have policy
makers who change their minds
in the state in the face of the facts
changing and i mean the the mantra for
some months has been data not dates um
although
the dates have been pretty dominant in
some of the decision making recently but
but having said that it's i would like
policymakers to respond to evidence
kate it's very easy for journalists like
us uh to criticize what is
uh to criticize the government in what
is an unprecedented crisis
uh should we just show them a little bit
more
charity i think actually a lot of good
faith
has been administered for this
government um you know we've had debates
on spectator tv
defending our editor fraser nelson
defending their decision to delay
uh freedom day by four weeks um you know
we were all shocked by that
you can you can you can try to
sympathize
but when they have these emergency
powers
which control our lives in such an
extreme way
and when we're talking about not getting
rid of all rules but exchanging the old
rules for
new rules that are indefinite and
potentially completely change the
relationship between the individual
and the state sympathy has to go out the
window you have to scrutinize that
because if you don't you end up i think
in a much darker place and
let's hope and that the cynics are right
let's hope that this is all a bluff and
that boris johnson
the once liberal editor of the spectator
he said that he would
tear up an identity card if he were ever
asked to show it and eat it
in front of the official who asked for
it let's hope that deep down in his
heart
he comes round and realizes what a bad
idea it would be to carve up society
based on their health status but as
they're announcing they're going to do
it saying this
is coming in without even having gone to
parliament first
i think our our only job freddie for the
next few week is to um
is to uh follow this and be critical
and uh investigate it thank you kate
thank you mark i'm now joined by douglas
murray
and we're going to be talking about
freedom and where the british people
actually wanted
douglas you in your brilliant column
this week you talk about how
there was an expectation that the 2020s
were going to be the roaring 20s
and in fact what you say is that they're
going to become the boring 2020s
what do you mean by that uh yes
this refers to something i actually
referred to in a column earlier this
year as well
nick christakis distinguished american
academic
made headlines in a way that american
academics tend not to
across the uk earlier this year when he
he said um
imposing that that perhaps the 2020s
would be like the 1920s
a great roaring decade uh and that just
as the the 1920s
were this great roaring decade following
the great war
so uh perhaps uh after the corona era
we would have this great roaring uh
party decade
of the 2020s and i of course
there's a reason why the media and
everyone else wanted to pick up on that
it's a sort of terrific story it's a
great claim
and it's uh for a lot of people anyway
it's something to look forward to
i pointed out by the way when i last
mentioned this story that
there's an obvious problem with it which
is that for most people the 1920s
weren't all that roaring
for a relatively small segment of
society they were
but for most people they just had to get
on with their jobs with their lives they
weren't all the cocktail parties with
the bright young things
and of course the whole decade ended in
a crash
so um i wasn't at all sure that i wanted
uh the the 2020s to be roaring like that
um and if it was going to be one great
big orgy
then i suspect as always that the
benefits would accrue to a very
relatively small number of people that
most people wouldn't get a look in
however uh yes i i've just expanded on
this
in my column this week really to make
a bit of a wider point which is that uh
there has been a feeling i think
uh through the pandemic but once once we
sort of got
through it we were really going to live
again you know
people were really just going to want to
get out there they were going to want to
do all the things they hadn't been
allowed to do
uh you know the the the horrible 18
months we've had
perhaps longer would be forgotten
and made up for and actually as i say in
my column i think the signs
are rather in the opposite direction
all the polls show a very significant
chunk of the british public
who don't they don't even want to mew
a let alone raw quite happy staying
home in the garden for the rest of their
lives
um want that even if all the
restrictions
are lifted and even if all of the
measurements to meet those restrictions
are met
and then you've got the other cultural
issues the other the other wider issues
which particularly i mentioned in the
column
is this very strange early warning sign
we already have of the extraordinary
program that's being shown to anyone who
is sort of wanting to get back
out there there's a deep sniffiness in
the air particularly in britain
a sort of sniffiness of the people
wanting to get back
out there particularly and i think this
is one of the most
unsettling things the deep sniffiness
about
young people wanting to get back out
there
and i think this in particular is quite
wrong and must be resisted
is it something that's getting worse
because i mean i think there's always
been a sort of undercurrent of suspicion
of
fun in britain where we we we sort of
came from puritanism after all
and i suppose from what i what i got
from your piece is that perhaps what
what what's happened is we're reverting
to what we were before which is a
a nation of people who don't really
trust people being
outdoors and enjoying themselves uh
we're suspicious
of of public pleasure yes that's right
i always think of that great h.l menken
quote about puritanism
you defined puritanism famously as the
sneaking
fear that someone somewhere was having
fun
there's a great streak of this in
britain always has been
and i think it's been exacerbated in the
last year because although
we may not have the puritan religion we
have the
version of it that replaces god with the
nhs
for instance you know that you are you
are risking the nhs
by having fun uh you are failing to do
your bit
to protect the great national
institution and their great national
deity
that you're being um selfish by enjoying
yourself and going out
and and as i say that in particular this
is likely to push a generational divide
that's already there
and generational divides already exist
but a generational divide that's
particularly there on the in the case of
this virus
um because what young people
i'm in my 40s now so i don't think i
count as that anymore but
but what young people in the late teens
and twenties
uh have had to give up in the last
18 months is very significant
they have been as i say in the piece
they have
been forced to for instance if their
students study alone
um many of them have lived alone they've
missed the opportunity to meet their
peers
they've been told unless they're in a
stable relationship to be monogamous
to be not just monogamous but actually
to be chased
the government has told them um to be uh
virgins or to at least engage in two
years of chastity
uh they have if they've followed the
rules they've
they've done that i'm not sure how many
have incidentally but
but if they follow the laws they've done
that they've these this is a
generation that has missed a significant
amount of its
lives and its opportunities to meet
friends to meet partners they've
they've studied alone they've run up
student debts alone they've graduated
alone
and i don't at all blame them that they
now want to get out there for a virus
that as can't be said often enough has
almost no effect has almost a negligible
effect
on people of their age groups so this
great demand has been made of them
and i think there's this lingering sense
that they should as it were
keep staying at home even though we have
had the vaccine
now the vaccine that by any
standard should be the passport out of
this
terrible ghastly era even after that
there's this sniffiness that they would
want to go out
to these large-scale events and i think
it's
i think it's cruel i think it's
unusually cruel
and i think with all the sort of adults
engaging in that sniffiness should
really
should really think about that i suppose
it's crueler than
puritanism in many ways or any kind of
theocratic thinking because it's
they're not saying to to people uh you
know you
don't uh sort of indulge your voices
because it's bad for you
they're saying don't do it because you
might harm someone else
yes that's right you might harm the nhs
you'll put the nhs under strain
and you'll kill other people uh as i say
when we get back to this thing either
the vaccine is the way out or it isn't
and um if it's the way out then life has
got to return to normal
and i i do for my own observation
keep noticing that it's britain
that seems to be worse than recognizing
this
you know the americans do seem to
realize i've made this comparison in a
number of places
the americans do seem to realize you
know once the vaccines in
you know you make your choice about
whether you take it or not uh but then
you just get
but get back out there and the british
don't seem to have
taken that view um i mean partly
because the government very very
misguidedly
uh suggested earlier this year that the
vaccine wasn't why
cases had fallen and that actually it
was locked down
but you know if the vaccine isn't the
way out then there is no way out of this
um and i think that's something that the
british in particular have got to focus
on but yes
you're right there is this there is this
sort of as we see in the public health
campaigns of recent uh weeks and months
where people are
you know being shown scary images of
people dying and basically being told
this would be something you'd cause
if you were to flout the rules is is a
form of coercion which is not just
ugly but untrue well uh perhaps the
martyr
of your piece if i could use that word
is charlie perry
uh the football fan who stuck
a red flare up his bottom and lit it
and it was a sort of uh viral sensation
the video of it was a viral sensation
and he received enormous amounts of
program and
uh sort of disgust really um and
that very much speaks to what you're
saying that we are um appalled at the
idea that someone
would go out and behave irresponsibly in
in a way that
british people might have been in the
50s yes i mean i
i should stress charlie bear is a
slightly unusual hero and
um but nevertheless it's important to
get this
this right yes as you say mr perry is a
25 year old roofer
who was very excited i think we can say
that
about the england uh um final in the
euros
uh playing against italy and uh mr perry
came to some national notoriety in
britain we should we should stress this
for our international viewers
uh mr perry came to some notoriety and
he made the front page of a number of
newspapers
because um on the relevant match day
um he he went large as you might say
he he drank he thinks about 20 cans of
cider which is
is quite a lot and
uh he also managed to get into the
ground for free
by jigging his way in about it they call
it uh
and so he was absolutely thrilled by the
whole day
couldn't have been happier and and
expressed this happiness in in
in some ways a traditional way uh by
um taking his trousers down in
trafalgar's in leicester square sorry
leicester square uh taking his trousers
down shoving a
flare up his backside and lighting it
and
um it may not be how you or i
would celebrate um england reaching the
finals of the euros but
but for mr perry it seemed to be the uh
the just the uh the the the the
just the ticket and um
he he actually said this the press after
uh vilifying him they caught up with him
he said in an interview
he's just thought that after 18 months
uh really miserable months he thought
the people needed a bit of cheering up
so it was a sort of public service in a
way in mr perry's mind
he certainly saw it that way and and
of course it is a dangerous thing to do
and we should stress in case there are
any children watching
that this is not advisable mr perry
didn't actually
feel fortunately the sparks
from the flare in his anus because he
drunk 20 cans of cider and
um if if you're going to avoid
it turns out the the the back flare of
of a flare 20 cans of cider is your
there are better ways of letting off
steam is what is what we will need to
yes and sparks and so so mr perry
um did this and what was interesting
about it was that this
is this is to my mind i mean as i say
you and i may not
may not favor this sort of form of
celebration but but
but this is pretty much what i expect of
england
football fans it's the sort of thing
they do and the crowd in leicester
square was absolutely thrilled
uh it went down very well among his
his friends and his newly acquired
friends it was just the nation as a
whole
that reacted with this universal
program to it which i just thought was
rather interesting because
i don't think he should be a national
hero um
but nor should he be regarded as a sort
of national villain
and there was this complete across the
media there was
this thing of um what a terrible thing
to do what an awful example to set
um what does this tell us about our
nation
what sort of image does this send out
and i just say that this reaction is an
example of something
which we've seen as well in the reaction
to young people going out to nightclubs
since monday this general sort of sense
that i don't like these
things and therefore these things are
wrong
and uh my own view is that you know
within the limits of the law if you
don't like things
don't do them and
don't be around people who do them i
mean you know
don't don't go to leicester square on a
match day
when you know it's going to be full of
lagged up uh football louds
um trying to set light to their
backsides so
you know just just just just you know
sort of one of the principles of a
tolerant society
is is that you let people do things that
you wouldn't yourself
do um so long as they're within the law
thank you very much for joining us
douglas let's go back to westminster and
talk to katie balls
and james forsythe about the week that
is going on
in sw1 james in your brilliant politics
column this week
you talk about how boris johnson has
addressed the biggest policy
issue of our times which is social care
and he has a big new plan on how to deal
with it
can you tell us a little bit about what
he's thinking what's going on
and what it says about the direction
that this government is going in
so two years ago when boris johnson
first became prime minister he promised
that he had a plan
to fix social care in the tory manifesto
he repeated that said no one would have
to pay for their house
to cover the cost of her social care uh
but i think it's fair to say that this
plan
was more an aspiration to have a plan
than a detailed plan
but i think if it wasn't for the fact
that the um health sector started jabba
has tested positive for kovid sending
himself and boris johnson rishi sunak
into self-isolation this week
i think we would have seen a social care
policy i think the expectation in
whitehall is that this policy would be
that national insurance or or some kind
of levy within national insurance
will rise to cover the cost of
a cap on social care costs and to
provide some money to deal with
the nhs backlog uh with nhs waiting list
now at five million people
such a challenge the health secretary
said that it might rise to 13 million
people
and i think i think this raises some big
political questions
uh first of all this is a tory
government raising taxes
to put more money into the health
service
now you can say that they're doing that
to honor that manifested pledge on
social care
but that also involves breaking a
manifesto pledge not to raise
income tax national insurance or vat i i
think it raises an interesting
dilemma for labor which is where does
the labour party go
when the tory party is pulling off the
trick that gordon brown did in 2002
of raising tax with the explicit aim of
putting that
extra revenue into the health service
and i think at the moment
this is a relatively politically
not that risky for the tories there is
no party to the right of them in
in british politics the low tax rights
of the tory party is not as politically
powerful as it was
but i think the question is in the long
term
what are you going to do because this
isn't going to be the last time that the
health service requires more money
and i mean there is a danger that unless
you think
about the size of a state but you know
the old joke about pakistan that it's a
military of a country attached
could end up being applicable to britain
that you know we could be a health
service of a country attached
katie i suppose as james says labour are
a bit stumped by this but
one would expect a little bit of tory
resistance is there any sign of
opposition in the ranks yes and
we heard some uh this week in the sense
that a cabinet minister giving an
interview quasi quarten
the business secretary suggested that
national insurance wouldn't be the
uh the right way to uh solely pay for
this
and i think it reflects uh wider unease
in the tory party about whether
uh a i think there's two points here is
the deal not proposal which is what the
prime minister favors
uh which is very expensive uh benefits
voters in the south potentially more
given at higher property prices
um in terms of uh protecting inheritance
if that was the right one for the
current party in terms of its coalition
and then also if even if you say that is
the right policy
is a national insurance hike uh
ultimately the right way to pay for this
because that is going to affect working
age
more than anyone else unless you bring
something extra in and
is it right that we have a situation
where the people who at least
immediately benefiting from this won't
be the ones contributing to it given
we've got lots of intergenerational
problems to begin with
and i think that as james has touched on
there was a sense that the prime
minister wanted to announce it this week
and almost just get it done but there
hadn't been much uh to float
with mps now we have a situation where
all the plans have eeked out
and you have months potentially of tory
mps
thinking about this potentially
complaining about it quite good at that
and uh causing issues and i think it
makes it harder potentially to land this
as a policy
james speaking in a more sort of global
sense is
is there is there any sort of coalition
anywhere uh in
in the western world for uh you know
individual responsibility
a kind of thatcherite uh conservatism it
seems that that's been abandoned
everywhere
yeah i think that if you look around the
world for the for a low-tax
small state center-right party you would
struggle to find one
uh i mean if you exclude the japanese
because they are uh
that their politics is slightly
different you know the only center right
finance minister
in the g7 is rishi sunak and i think if
you
say so i think politics has clearly
moved in this direction i think that we
are
i mean we've discussed this in the
spectator before fred
we are moving into an into a into an era
of a bigger state
and bigger government and i think one of
the things that casey touched on her
answer is
what are challenges those sovereign tall
receipts that you would expect to
normally be the home of kind of
low tax fiscal conservatism
to them protecting the right to pass on
their house
to uh their children is that
trumps low taxes in their hearts and
minds that is the gamble that boris
johnson is taking
and i think if you talk to troy mps it's
a it's a fairly safe one in those
prosperous commuter belt seats
people you know the guarantee that they
won't end up having to sell their house
for care
is more important to them than a belief
in
in low taxes one might cynically add
particularly because the tax the tories
are thinking about raising
is not one paid by the over 65s
katie do you think uh recalcitrantory
mps are just going to have to get with
the
big state program on this i think
they're going to have to get the big
state program
but i also think that they're in terms
of who pays and what i think some of
that is still to play for because boris
johnson has a majority
of around 80 and ultimately i think that
has been shown to not be quite what it
seemed on paper
i think this government actually has an
issue driving reform
and we're going to see more of that
because tory mps aren't particularly
happy and ultimately
they can show that with votes when it
comes to various parts of legislation so
i think we are heading to a government
that will raise taxes in some form
and break manifested pledges but i think
in terms of
how exactly that plays out i think there
is still some battles to come
uh james there is another political
story that's bubbling up that we should
talk about this week and that's northern
ireland
uh the uk wants to have another look at
the trading protocol can you explain
in layman's terms please uh what's going
on there uh
i'll do my best fred so the northern
army protocol was signed as part of the
withdrawal agreement so it was signed
by the british government when boris
johnson first became prime minister when
it was still a home parliament
and it essentially conceded that uh in
various ways norman island would remain
uh in the single market in the customs
union even after brexit but it would
still
also be in the uk customs union there
are a whole bunch of procedures in this
uh i think the uk government agreed this
to get a deal done because it wanted a
deal to fight the election on
and it is it is now seeking what it
admits are substantial
changes to the protocol the eu's
reaction has been predictably to say
uh no uh and then in private to point
out hang on second
this is the prime minister who
negotiated this protocol who signed this
protocol
how can he now say that he wants changes
to it
i think the kind of question is uh does
this become a kind of frozen dispute
almost
uh where the two sides agree to a
standstill
uh the uk doesn't invoke article 16. uh
the eu slows its legal actions against
the uk
and we just exist in a situation where
this is a kind of you know like
a kind of frozen negotiation that just
sits there
with neither side prepared to to totally
push it
um but both prepared to live with the
kind of messiness of the moment
or as i think there are lots of people
in
uh brussels and various eu member states
think that you should do hello look
we've got it you know
the uk sign this we've got to push them
to abide by it and i think
i think it is interesting as well the
uk's proposals for changes to the
protocol
these aren't tweaks these are really
substantial changes
and one of the other big questions is
is this an opening maximalist
negotiating position from the uk
side uh or is this
them saying unless we get all this we
will invoke article 16
uh and everyone will have to go back to
the drawing board
i understood that very well thank you
james more brexit limbo is
is the gist as always with northern
ireland it's never quite done
thank you james thank you katie now onto
afghanistan it seems as though the war
in afghanistan the forever war as it's
often been called
is finally over western forces are
withdrawing
but is that morally the right thing to
do do we
owe anything more to afghanistan as the
western powers who invaded it
i'm joined now by tom tugenhart who's
chairman of the foreign affairs select
committee
and andrew coburn who is washington
editor
of harper's magazine tom i'll start with
you as someone who's served in
afghanistan
you clearly think that we have let down
the region and we've let down ourselves
and cause more danger for the west by
withdrawing from this conflict
can you explain to me why you think that
yes of course i think there was a strong
argument to make that the uk and the
united states should not have got into
nation building there was certainly a
very strong argument to make
in 2001 that the destruction of the
taliban or rather the destruction of
al-qaeda was the key aim and we should
have
walked away at that point but after we'd
invested so much
in the last 10 years the fighting really
stopped for the west certainly for the
united states and the uk
about four years ago since then we've
actually been
enabling afghan security forces there's
been about
10 000 nato troops two and a half
thousand or so
u.s troops enabling some 400 000
afghan national security forces now you
can argue
that they shouldn't have got into the
mission in the first place but the idea
that that was a major commitment
is not sustainable when you look at the
hundreds of thousands of u.s troops
deployed
in places like south korea or germany
it simply is a a statement that
what we were doing was actually trying
to buy
a bit of time for the governments or the
various different parties to negotiate
and in withdrawing what we did was pull
the rug under all
i suppose the obvious question then is
um
i mean how much time do we need how much
time does afghanistan need it's been 20
years
uh do we have to do it does the west
have a responsibility to be a kind of
security operation in afghanistan
into the indefinite future
i don't think the west really is part of
the security solution
except the most basic level but that
doesn't mean that it's not
uh an important element within it and
the reality is you know some of our
security forces have endured
for many many years before they've
actually been able to withdraw easily
you know if you look at germany for
example the the last day of fighting in
1945 was not the final victory the final
victory
was the fall of the cold you know the
fall of the berlin wall and the end of
the cold war in the 1990s
and the same is true in south korea the
the reality is
many ways the war isn't over in the
sense that u.s troops are still
guaranteeing
south korean prosperity and and ensuring
stability in the area
but the choice isn't simply you know do
we stay or do we go
but what are the alternatives to staying
and what are the alternatives to going
and here the alternative to staying
is uh an empowered taliban likely with
chinese support through pakistan and a
different
uh perception of the united states and
the west
uh around the world now that's that's a
choice i think it's an unwise one but it
is a choice and that's the choice that
president biden has made
andrew i'll bring you in now uh you've
written a brilliant piece
uh for the upcoming edition of spectator
world about
uh the costs of war in afghanistan to
the pentagon
um and i think we'll get on to that in a
second but first of all could you just
respond to
what tom has said there uh i imagine you
disagree
well i do i mean not not not totally
because i agree with what he said that
it was a great mistake for them to
uh um you know 20 years ago or
to get into the business of nation
building
which was done in a very crass way but
for a discussion all the time but the um
unfortunately
you know if there'd been steady progress
if the whole thing had been working
um then there might have been an
argument for staying
but uh clearly for the last four years
and for the
many years before that the thing was
basically going nowhere
i mean everyone i've talked to um
you know who's been in the military been
in the u.s
you know the state department you know
they all would have been confiding for
years
that they felt this was you know not
going to succeed that the afghan
security forces because of the
ramshackle and highly corrupt
state apparatus that we'd really created
or
certainly fostered um this was you know
hiding to nowhere and actually we have
we've had high-level
confirmation of that from the so-called
afghanistan papers which were
finally revealed in the washington post
a while ago it turned out that all the
u.s generals were saying in private for
20 years
this war is unwinnable we're never going
to succeed
they said something different to us the
taxpayers but
you know privately they didn't believe
it so
i'm afraid you know i'm i'm sorry that
it's you know going to
certainly you know result in more
suffering and misery in afghanistan
but it already was i mean it's
you know for years now we well quite a
while we've been hearing that the
government forces were causing more
civilian casualties than the taliban
you know this was not some anything on
the way to success
what do you make of this argument that
um afghanistan
we hear it quite a lot that afghanistan
will become a
terrorist haven uh again uh following
withdrawal um well i i
really don't buy it i mean the um
uh terrorists have found lots of other
places to
find havens ever since then but notably
syria but
that's taliban i think they you know
they've learned a lot in the years of
the
fighting for the fighting comeback and
one of them is not to
attract people you know to be take a
headline role
in headquartering a terrorist
organizations attacking the united
states so i
really don't think that uh we're going
to see a prominent
al qaeda or isis uh you know presence in
afghan in afghanistan
here on in tom do you disagree with that
not terribly except that i don't think
the taliban is a thing
so the taliban doesn't actually have the
choice the taliban is simply a brand
name given to anybody who doesn't like
the government
plenty of them are very closely allied
to isis
today already and are harboring them
today
already as we saw with the murder of the
halo trust people in
barachon only a few weeks ago
so i mean it's not it's not that the
taliban has made a
you know geopolitical choice to harbor
or not to harbor terrorists
it's that it is a completely diffuse
bunch of
warlords of different sizes some of whom
are quite happy harboring terrorists and
some of whom
see the dangers that that brings what
about this china point do you think
andrew do you think that um uh we should
worry about china getting involved in
this
graveyard of empires as it's often
called or might some people think
uh if if china wants to get bogged down
in afghanistan then
that might not be the worst news for the
west
well yeah very good point i mean i think
it'd be wonderful
well we'd know be very sad actually if
there was
unfortunate afghans were subject to
another 40 years of war but uh
it wouldn't be great for the chinese to
you know try and
do what we failed to do and what the
russians
failed to do which is to somehow control
afghanistan tom do you think do you
think china wants to
control afghanistan in the way that uh
america or not control but you want it
wants to sort of have the kind of
influence that america and britain did
in afghanistan we know i know that it it
has quite a lot of sway in pakistan
does it want to do the same thing in
afghanistan it certainly wants to have
some influence i'm not quite sure i'd
say it's the same but it wants to have
some influence they've already
got quite serious economic interests in
terms of copper mining and things like
that
they already have some strategic
interests we know that they've reached
out to some taliban groups
about the weak or muslim population in
xinjiang
trying to silence any potential
connections between the two groups so
they're clearly concerned about
it whether or not they want to do much
more motorways
or train lines or whatever i i don't
know i mean i would be surprised i think
that'd be rather ambitious
but you know they certainly are looking
at uh
afghanistan as many countries have
looked at afghanistan for for many years
as
a potential place of danger and unrest
and
something they wish to control and you
know the us
did the same admittedly from rather
greater range and
effectively what it's just done is its
massive cost saving is a saving of 1
900 troops that's it that's less than a
brigade
well there's obviously the human element
but andrew you've written this
piece about uh the the extraordinary
uh costs of this war and i mean perhaps
i'm putting too much spin on it but i
would say
that what i got from that piece that was
that
the afghanistan war became a kind of
extortion racket
for uh arms firms and
the pentagon to extract more and more
money out of this crisis and i was very
interested that there was
actually a a particular budget that the
pentagon had to do operations in
afghanistan on
top of its enormous budget could you
tell us a little bit about that
right it was called um overseas
contingency
funds um which as i say in the piece you
know it's rather like a police
department charging extra
for chasing criminals um i mean the
defense department is there
presumably to defend us and to wage war
if necessary and then they were
charging extra for um uh if
you know for fighting in afghanistan and
in uh
iraq and the troop deployments in syria
and a whole bunch of other places in the
in northern africa and so forth um
that's now come to an end i think quite
rightly i mean if they're
you know it's ridiculous to have this
sort of add-on for the privilege of
uh defending us or fighting our wars
well i look i agree completely the
generals shouldn't be used to make
political statements i think it's
absolutely
absurd if the war is worth fighting the
politicians to justify it and the
soldiers should fight it
if it is not worth fighting the soldiers
should stop fighting it but at no stage
should the military have a say in
whether or not a
an operation is is achievable we have
militaries that are controlled by
elected politicians and there's a
purpose for that but in
a in a democracy a politician should be
answerable to the people and it seems
certainly in america
it seems from uh we saw with donald
trump and
now with biden that withdrawing from
afghanistan and ending the forever wars
is a popular move why should politicians
not do
what the american or the british public
want
well i think the american public and
british public want
many things and they're absolutely right
that we don't want to be engaged in
forever wars and i
think i made this point in 2001 2002
that getting drawn in
was probably a mistake and you know i
certainly made the argument
in private then i'm not sure i'm not
sure anybody was listening
but uh but i did make it then and the um
and the reality is that
we've now got ourselves into a situation
where by 20
well certainly five six years ago you
know most of the fighting had finished
to the extent that we have you know two
and a half thousand u.s troops of whom 1
900 are withdrawing and 600 are still
staying to guard the embassy anyway
so it's a the withdrawal of about
half a brigade combat team not a
credible fighting unit in the united
states
terms that has simply been enabling now
you you may argue that it wasn't
achieving anything anyway that's a
legitimate argument
i argue that it was sustaining at least
some form of stability uh was it moving
in the right direction
well it wasn't a complete failure um
and for that investment maybe it was
worth it now the sunk cost that andrew
has spoken about are absolutely real
but there's no way they're coming back
you know that money is spent those men
sadly are dead
we're not bringing them back the
decision is what do we do going forward
not how do we correct the past
i just like to make one observation here
which is the it's slightly misleading to
think of the us
involvement recently as just you know
1900 troops i mean the
crucial the main contribution they've
been making is air power
uh out of bagram uh coming out of
kandahar too they were still flying out
of there
particularly using drones oh okay not
kind of um
so that that was you know that was the
crucial component
really propping up the uh uh the uh
afghan security situation um and i just
want to say well you know talking a lot
about the money i agree
talking about the money in a way i think
the money was part of the problem
i mean john subco who was the special
insect inspector general that i quote in
the piece
for afghan reconstruction he said we've
we've created a state or we're
supporting a state we're enabling a 10
billion dollar budget
for a state that could otherwise only
sustain a 2 billion
budget in other words it was an
unsustainable state without us without
this
massive infusion of aid which um
i think when the uh former ambassador
ron crocker
said a few years ago u.s ambassador said
you know
inject pouring that a huge amount of
money into a fragile society fragile
state apparatus
you're going to inevitably going to have
massive corruption
so the idea that you know it's
particularly american thing of
throwing more and more money at a
problem in you know hopes that that'll
produce a solution actually helps
helps ensure failure and that's what we
did in afghanistan
can can i ask you just just to close it
um very both very briefly i'll start
with tom
do you think the do you think we have
ended our involvement in afghanistan or
do you think we are going to find
ourselves drawn back in
uh because of uh the situation in
afghanistan and as it unravels there'll
be a humanitarian crisis and
our involvement is not in fact over no i
think this is
really the end of our involvement in
afghanistan
the idea that we could get very involved
in a humanitarian crisis if we don't
have
the ability to oversee at least some of
it through agencies or through
different forms of uh envoys i think is
unlikely i mean let's see right but it's
it strikes me that the withdrawal of the
troops means effectively the embassies
and the aid work will wind down as well
maybe not immediately but certainly over
coming years
and that in reality is the end of our
involvement andrew
well i absolutely agree i don't think uh
the american
public would stand for the congress
would stand for you know
afghanistan two or three um
that it's inconceivable and it's
actually very difficult one thing we
haven't you know
anywhere out of time but that we haven't
mentioned in this discussion is pakistan
and pakistan you know was always the you
know the
man behind the curtain in this um uh
the taliban you know whatever whatever
whatever you want to call them wouldn't
have made the comeback they have without
consistent support in pakistan and the
pakistan was going to make very
sure actually i think that we we never
succeeded we never had a stable
uh government uh uh
uh supporting us in in in kabul
um controlling the countryside
and uh you know now of course we don't
have a base anywhere nearer than the
gulf so it'd be very hard to intervene
again
thank you andrew and thank you tom
now finally we're going to be talking
about the rise of convenience technology
and the decline of western civilization
i'm joined by
sam leath our literary editor who had
the misfortune
of having his car stolen last week and
i'd like sam to tell me a little bit
about how that happened
sam over to you well we we have this car
which as i
as i say in the piece it's it's not a
really fancy car but it's a slightly
fancy car it's the nicest car i've ever
had it's a land rover discovery sport
which is kind of
entry-level suv type thing and suitable
for karting my family of
five including two interrupts there and
say i was i was actually very impressed
by the smartness of your car oh well
thank you
thank you how does a journalist get that
was my first thought
oh well he's vastly overpaid by the
spectator as you know
um we all are we all are um anyway
so we have this quite fancy car and it's
great because it has seven seats so you
can put the children right at the back
and you know it actually drives rather
than simply slowing down when you try
and
approach a roundabout you know sort of
go up a hill or whatever um
anyway so very happy with the car it's
got this keyless fancy entry fob which
i was like that's great no more you know
difficulty in having to turn the key or
you just have it in your pocket you
climb in off you go it's
it's lovely um anyway the keyless thing
means that it's very very easy
it turns out for thieves to nick them
and as the police told us
um when on saturday morning um we
discovered it gone they said oh
land rover land rovers range rovers and
keyless jaguars
are the ones that are stolen all the
time
um sorry our story i'll tell you to tell
you
my wife arrives home with the children
from wherever she's been with them
go you know unloads them leaves the car
on the drive just outside the front of
the house we live on quite a busy street
in london but
um we've got a bit of off street parking
so they you know there's
there's the car there and on saturday
morning she
goes out in order to drive off to go to
football and
goes where's the car i said obviously
it's where you've left it
you drove it last it was in the front
drive no it isn't
um and of course it's gone no broken
glass no nothing just
vanished um and i mean this is another
story but we
she'd finally made it to football i
think in an uber or on her bicycle and
then fractured her foot and
24 hours later she was diagnosed with
kovid so it was a very bad
week for us but anyway there we are car
car is missing
and it turns out like our neighbor has
cctv
on their drive so just out of the corner
of the thing you can see this person
you can see it like quarter to five in
the morning
just see the corner of our car in the
corner of the screen
and somebody just kind of character just
appears in the corner
opens the door climbs in and drives off
just as if they'd had the key which
presumably they did um i mean not
actually the key the key but there's
different ways they can do it
they either clone the key or they
kind of get hold of the signal from the
key because it you've left it near the
front of the house which we didn't so i
don't know how that's
that happened they boost it so
they boost they boost it yeah one of the
ways they do it and i was sort of on the
tv for this because i read somewhere
that keyless car theft was kind of easy
and therefore
when you have your key you should keep
it a long way away from the car you know
not by the front door on the windowsill
which is where a lot of people leave it
but they they come up to the front of
the house with a
doohickey i think it's a technical term
um
and that picks up the signal and then
boosts it off to another doohickey which
is next to your car
which then fools the car into thinking
the key's in it and
off it goes not quite sure once they've
driven to wherever they're going
they then restart it not sure how they
do that they can't use their single
booster anymore but no doubt they have
ways
well reading your account uh and hearing
you tell it i was just reminded of
it happened to us once at our car we
looked out the front of the house and
the car was missing but it was actually
because we were living in
america at the time and it was on a hill
and it was a jeep
and the handbrake had come off and it
just rolled
down the bottom of the hill had come off
and then been taken away by a by an
impounding uh local impounding service
so we um we eventually got it back but
it took a while but that was a very old
and crummy car
what i'm struck by what you're saying is
that it seems to be the more expensive
your car because i know it happens with
tesla's too
uh the more likely it is to get stolen
which is quite a strange well it's not
strange that the more expensive your car
the more likely it is to get stolen
i think what's strange is that the more
expensive your car the easier it is to
steer the easier it is
it's obviously a bigger target yeah i
mean that's the thing because i i would
sort of thought because
you know charles corrin and someone i've
known a bit for many years and you know
i've sort of became aware
that giles's car was constantly being
pinched
and he's got this really fancy kind of
jaguar
half electric top of the range thing
called a jaguar eye pace
and i was like well no wonder they're
always stealing jars this car cause he's
got a really fancy car whereas my car
isn't
not that fancy it'll be fine because
there's loads of
discovery sports around on the street
but anyway it turns out all of them are
stolen
what you get onto in the meat of the
piece really is about how
uh convenience um has made us all
terribly terribly lazy uh and that
uh you talking about amazon and so on
um all all sort of technology now is
used to make us less
and less uh responsible
for our possessions well i think so i
mean i
my thesis in the piece really was
because i sort of said
like these keyless entry systems which
obviously are a way of you know
make it easier for your car to be stolen
they're still massively prevalent and
they're prevalent i think because you
know
they're attractive because they're so
convenient but
you know the trouble of turning a key in
a lock
is not really an enormous trouble you
know it's a couple of seconds worth of
difficulty um
it's not like you know for years the
people have been yearning to be free of
the need to actually stick their key
into the car
steering columns to turn the car on and
now it lasts
and i think that that that does
percolate through the whole of
our culture and particularly our economy
that there's a sense in which
we're so accustomed to convenience so
keen on it
that we will trade an awful lot for the
most
marginal increases in convenience
including
security i mean of course online you
know
so much of what we do and so much of the
digital economy is geared to the idea
that people can't be asked to read the
terms and conditions that people will
submit to any number of of sort of
potential invasions their privacy
or you know um
different risks online if you like
simply for the convenience of being able
to
you know use i don't know a cloud app
that allows you to
you know edit your document wherever
you're going or
get free email or get you know all the
different things that we rely on online
make our lives more convenient you know
amazon's another classic example is that
it makes it much much
more convenient to shop because you just
sit at home you go oh
you know amazon's you know they don't
pay their taxes and they're exploitative
of their workers and you know all their
baddies you know if you're a sort of
hand-drinking type like me
um but oh going to the bookshops
hours and this you know by tomorrow
afternoon i've got this book in my hands
and it's cost me half the price now bang
well sam i wonder in light of this if
whether you're going to change your car
and go back to a more traditional key
car or
if you get your car back you're just
going to be very relieved and you'll go
back to enjoying your
keyless entry to your vehicle well you
see i'm very lazy because i've been
conditioned by
you know late capitalism to be so um but
so i'm probably not going to change my
car
because that would be even more effort
um but i have bought
a faraday box which is the thing that
stops them boosting it
and one of those big yellow bars that
you put across the steering wheel which
apparently because thieves love
convenience as well
and for them keyless cars are great
because they're very convenient to steal
whereas if you put an old-fashioned
crook lock on it
um it makes it inconvenient for them so
they can't be bothered um
so the circle sort of you know the wheel
does come full circle in that respect
so i'm going to make a bit more effort
to secure my car um and hopefully that
will be
a bar to entry for the thieves well i
hope you avoid any more headaches and
thank you very much for for bothering to
come on thank you
uh that is it for this week
uh i hope you enjoyed the show and if
you did
or even if you didn't please subscribe
to
the spectators youtube channel you can
do that by hitting the button at the
bottom of the screen
and also i'd encourage you to hit the
bell which will remind you every time we
produce
a new episode there we go thank you very
much for watching
please tune in again next time
[Music]
you